the ghosts of recessions past haunt
britain's towns and cities
the bombed-out ruins of the old coventry
cathedral watched over a post-war boom
until the bust of the 80s hit this city
hard an energy crisis sky high inflation
a hike in interest rates all eerily
familiar covetry has bounced back but
with the price of everything going up
the warning of a return to recession is
no surprise to those who remember the
80s
jesuita was in her 20s the struggles now
strikingly similar to back then
it was very difficult for people because
the house prices had gone up
the food had gone up
and the wages had never gone up and it
was very difficult for big families to
try and
make the ends meet so what do you want
for tea tonight mortgages food bills all
add up even for families with good
incomes
vicky works full-time and so does her
husband
we don't keep a lot on offerage
wastage we can't afford to be chucking
food in the bin dinner out is out of the
question
family plans for the summer are
different this year
if i'm honest i'd just like to be able
to go out like we used to for days out
without having to
watch the bank balance watch what's
coming in what's going out what might
happen in the winter
just having to plan so much ahead
because the income that you know comes
into the house is going out on bills and
everything else as everything just gets
more and more expensive
when families like vicki's stop spending
businesses start to feel it that's going
to reduce demand elsewhere in the
economy and the bank of england at least
thinks that that's going to mean over
time
rising unemployment
and
lower output so a recession for the
whole uk economy
the starkest of warnings that the
present crisis will deepen with the
worst still yet to come becky johnson
sky news in coventry